premium and welcome everyone we are
meeting here under the auspices
the center for international conflict or
the center for international conflict
resolution who's director is sitting
here in place work I will achieve for
the fifth in the series of that public
interviews with distinguished
international players in the future
deviation negotiation are dressed today
I guess today is serrano pepper as a bad
effort was the first recruit that the
second worked very closely firstly with
the executive secretary of the
commission that eventually led to the
setting up of the United Nations as such
and then worked very closely with every
other five first secretaries and the
general now he is the better of a three
wonderful books one's a biography of
that commercial where is his a biography
of Ralph Bunche the United Nations first
nobel peace prize norway's and finally a
memoir a life in peace and war and those
of you who are students of the Second
World
war and will be interested to learn that
had sir Brian's advice being followed
operation Market Garden would perhaps
have been a success or at least not
debacle he may want to tell us a bit
about that you would have to be a bit of
a student because in the film that was
made of that particular episode a bridge
too far for some odd reason the
character who played sir Brian was given
another surname and that is something
that perhaps want Sean corner easy go
the problem I see yes yes what is also
called darker than the foot yes you
can't have two workers I would confuse
now sir Brian's a name is most
frequently associated with peacekeeping
which was one of the innovations one of
the creations of the United Nations for
from the very beginning and I was just
rereading Brian's biography of Ralph
Bunche where he reveals that some of the
key principles associated with
peacekeeping were in fact a decisions
taken executive decisions taken by ralph
bunche himself in setting up the
original the first peacekeeping or the
first piece observation operations I'd
like you Brian perhaps just to to start
perhaps to reflect a bit in retrospect
about how you see the original
conception of the United Nations
as compared to what it became yes well i
think that the important thing if you're
looking at the beginning of the United
Nations is to realize this in fact
originally was a military organization
it was founded in nineteen it's the
January the first 1942 with the
Declaration of the United Nations in
Washington of 26 countries were at that
point fighting the wall and I suppose it
was perfectly natural therefore that
everybody would assume that the Alliance
which won the war would stick together
to look after the peace there was never
a more foolish assumption but that's
what they thought and of course the
original the original form of the URL of
the UN was a great power alliance
wrapped up in an international
organization and we were actually I
missing I can definitely it shows how
simple minded people are because
everybody at they were throwing their
hats in the air about this at the
beginning just after the life of the war
ended things that wonderful you know
chums the Russians and so on with us and
so on the only people who didn't think
it was wonderful i have to say was the
Soviet Union they were very sour right
from the beginning and I think they were
right they didn't think that this they
were not in a jovial mood at all not
least because they had suffered huge
casualties in the war and were
economically completely devastated and
therefore they were extremely nervous of
the United they also did not have a
nuclear weapon they were extremely
nervous of the United States anyhow it
didn't last I mean after about a year
the first person I think who really got
it right about the organization of the
away and the five permanent members of
the Security Council and the veto was
Ernie Bevan with the amazing Foreign
Secretary of great britain during the
war any bevan missing you
man and he said whenever I see the
Russians it reminds me of the plumbers
strike in Bristol in 19 3 Kos Ronda
works with understand owner that meant
but he was pretty bad the plumber strike
in Bristol in 93 but in this without
inside this old trade unionist there was
a tremendous dislike of communism and a
real he didn't feel that these were good
union man these the Soviet people we
were dealing with and of course he was
perfectly right there weren't and that
that swept like a sort of disease
through the UN after about a year I mean
we everybody had been very much sort of
energized to think how wonderful he were
more President Roosevelt has sadly
Stevenson and now that poetry his name
escapes me a famous American poet well
it'll come back to me around the United
States for a whole year before the San
Francisco conference to tell the
American people that the charter of the
United Nations this was a good thing and
it was something that they needed just
as much as everybody else did I think
they were much too successful because I
not remember when we first got to the
United States in March 1946 people were
amazed at how you already how hostile
the Security Council was and what
terrible things people said about each
other it was a huge letdown I don't
really know that it's it what's the
other thing about the UN was it set up
it was set up to deal with as great
organizations usually are to deal with
the situation before it was to deal with
what had happened in the interwar period
between nineteen nineteen and 9039 which
was a period of aggression a period of a
huge economic depression which had led
in a number of countries to a takeover
by the Nazis or the fascists or a
military regime and particularly
aggression was actually not something
which was really about to happen after
the war you had a much more complicated
situation you had to ideological empires
at really at loggerheads with each other
and sometimes looking as if they were
going to fight and of course nobody had
also foreseen curiously enough the third
main thing the UM us set up to do which
was to do something about empires I've
just been reviewing a book I think by
one of your colleagues here person of
our quarterly know enchanted palace and
it's very very interesting on the the
role that the empires and particularly
the British Empire played in the setting
up both of the League of Nations and of
the United Nations and until quite late
on I think that a lot of people thought
that in some inscrutable way the UN was
going to be or less based on the
position to us except the French empires
and this summer I was going to be a
basis for carrying on well actually this
it turned out very soon this was a this
was a complete non-starter in fact one
of the great surprises in the history of
the UN is the speed with which
decolonization took place I me about the
people were talking about a hundred or
150 years in 1945 and the whole process
of decolonization was effectively over
in about 20 years which again has
completely altered not only the size of
the direction of the organization but
also the kind of things it needs to do I
go on forever so that you better blow
with the wife well you already I your
your adjustment I don't want to cut you
off just as you've known up to the rest
of the question that I one of the things
about being old is that you have no idea
how long we've been talking for watch
out boy well this cases it's absolutely
wonderful but that now of course because
of the onset of the Cold War I mean
there was a certain disappointment well
a certain disappointment is putting it
rather my only it was a major
disappointment the United Nations didn't
quite stand up to what it was what was
expected of it but of course the Cold
War was was around for four
long long time a good about for decades
approximately V and that rather tied the
hands of secretaries general didn't it
yes it did and it also made them much
more important curiously enough I mean
tell us how well I think that the I mean
anybody in the Secretary to had time to
think about anything on this capable of
doing so realized after about ten months
that something was seriously wrong an
after all we had the first secretary
general trivially of Norway was more or
less excommunicated by the Soviet Union
because he bet he vigorously backed the
security council decision to to go into
Korea to fight the North Korea and
invaded the south and so you had a very
honest oakwood pretending that this was
the love feast that everybody been
thinking about it San Francisco it just
wasn't I think the next Secretary
General dark hammer salt well we'll come
to that in a minute but the rightful
thing about dark hammer short was that
he was selected by the permanent members
of the Security Council in the belief
that he was an extremely dull Swedish
civil sins and of course he turned out
to be something rather the opposite of
that he was a ball of fire and he very
much realized that there was something
to be done in the cold war in the UN and
possibly the secretary-general was one
of the very few people could do it
because he in theory it had already had
been elected both why the Russians and
the Americans I mean they both approved
of his his of his secretary generalship
largely as I said because they didn't
know anything about image was excellent
and he really in the political field i
think was looking for an opportunity to
show that if you got into a dangerous
situation in the Cold War and
particularly if you got into a situation
where the Chinese were involved
so they were not at that point they
weren't representing China in the in the
UN they're not yet got the Chinese seat
then the Secretary General possibly was
about the only person who would talk to
all to all of them and try to get away
from it and by sheer chance he had a
very good opportunity to prove that
because when he became Secretary General
in let c1950 see what 453 51 52 or fifty
250 I can't really but there was a it
was the aftermath of the Korean War and
there was a there were four American
fighter pilots and a b-29 crew who had
can't all of whom had condom had
parachuted in China there for one reason
or another they had run out of gas or
something and the Chinese had the courts
had condemned them a spy's I don't think
was altogether surprising they condemned
the b-29 crew because the aircraft was
absolutely full of intelligence gadgets
of one sort mother and about a ton of
leaflets as well so rather hard to say
these are honest bomber party they were
something a bit more than that but this
was a major a major crisis because it
was in the days of John Foster Dulles
and the United States was not speaking
to the Chinese and nothing on God's
earth would persuade them to speak to
them and so they brought the case to the
Security Council the Security Council no
just the General Assembly first oh the
General Assembly sort of waved at sounds
of the earth said oh it's very difficult
to pass situation and then it ended up
with the usual sentence request the
secretary-general to take this matter
under advisement or something like that
and then it went to the Security Council
and by that time people were driving up
and down in Washington and suggesting
nuclear strikes on the Chinese mainland
and that kind of thing and it really was
extremely dangerous and the Security
Council referred the matter again to the
secretary gentleman
what a surprise Hamilton IV was leaving
for China the next day well that's true
pop the permanent members i must say and
Dallas was quite upset about this is he
really going to talk to these people and
I'm sure some you know you can try to
get anything out of people it's really
best to be able to talk to him it
doesn't really matter whether their
enemies or friends but do that this was
not a point of view that was well
received i can tell you now the Russians
were extremely upset because they didn't
think the secretary done ought to be
doing this kind of thing but they did on
the other hand they did not want to have
a huge mess involving the the People's
Republic of China and the United States
which was what eleventh Leon the cards
how much shorter who really loved this
kind of thing and was very good at it
had sort of rehearsals of what he was
going to do in Beijing and then the
Chinese said are you coming as a as a as
a representative of the Security Council
because they they keep condemning us
because we won't have that he said oh no
no no I'm coming under a rather
particular formula in particular for my
foot it didn't exist it was he had
worked out this idea that in certain
circumstances when the things were
dangerous enough the Secretary General
had an obligation to try to do something
about it not in any or ordering
run-of-the-mill confrontations but in a
real world class crazy so this certainly
was that and Joel I was delighted with
that both he and Hamish wrote very much
like very very long sort of historical
philosophical discussions and once I
know which is why the talks L took so
long but that was fine and he did
eventually in a period of six months he
got the fighter pilot side first because
there was very question by them and then
there was the problem with the b-29 crew
that he did he had two civilian members
who were in the CIA was they discovered
who he couldn't deal with because they
were I mean there was every reason to
put them in jail if you were Chinese
they were there were agents but the crew
itself which was
think 13 people that was it was very
difficult because the Chinese had to
overturn a legal decision of their own
courts and they didn't want to do that
and then we noticed in in our office
that we kept getting inquiries from the
Chinese ambassador and stop him about
commercials birthday and then it turned
out it was going to be his 50th birthday
or July the 29th and they were beaming
when they heard that and sure I'm a
short within a very very obscure fishing
village in southern Sweden which didn't
have a post office or a telephone very
helpful and a telegram arrived at this
place saying that the Chinese government
thought that he'd like to know that the
plumber crew had was on its way by train
to carloon and was going to Hong Kong
and he said of course they were you know
they violated chinese sovereignty with
the worst possible intentions but
nonetheless and then it said the
government of the People's Republic of
China wish to express their appreciation
and congratulations to establish on his
50th birthday and then then I think they
also in some side note said you better
not try to explain this to in Washington
do they would get it but this is the
earliest what we had to do there were
many wavy well that was the this proton
assault on the map as someone who could
be trusted to take on extremely
difficult situations and not make a mess
of it and of course his whole efforts
particularly with peacekeeping was to
try to turn situations round which might
lead to an open confrontation between
the East and the West and particularly
between the Soviet Union and the United
States this was the object after the
suez crisis when there were very ominous
noises coming out of out of Moscow about
what they were going to do with the
British in friendship they didn't get
out of Egypt and in the Congo later on
it was
the same thing and in a number of
situations and I think Hamish olds great
feeling was that un couldn't do
what it was supposed to do which was to
deal with aggressors first of all
because there weren't any conventional
aggressors except possibly the great
powers and in the second place that you
if you didn't have the five permanent
members on board you didn't have any
forces because the original plan was
that the permanent members would
mobilize almost on a wartime scale to
back up ay ay ay un decision as they did
in Korea when their Soviet Union well to
stop it but I think if you look at how
marshalls a heap he really did have a
very kind kind of philosophical mind
which sort of saw in stages quite far
ahead and he didn't want to rush things
for example after we put the first
peacekeeping force not thee what Alvaro
was talking about the observer group in
Palestine in Kashmir in 1948 but in 1956
we improvised this peacekeeping force
that had not been done before and John
Foster Dulles who was actually about
this point dying of cancer but he was
still Secretary of State was absolutely
over the moon about the peacekeeping
force he thought it was absolutely you'd
have one he thought it was wonderful and
he contrived to get the both houses of
Congress tour dr. resolution urging a
standing peacekeeping force well how
much things have changed some day but
anyhow it was quite interesting nobody
except me ever seems to have heard of it
but it's true he also wrote a letter so
how short saying it was very very
important to have this standing
peacekeeping force get it going and
having it there so that we can go
whizzing into whatever it was how much
it was extremely reluctant about this he
said you know it's very dangerous you
can't do this in the first place how do
you know that the next situation is
going to be suitable for that how do you
know which governments are going to be
acceptable which are not in a
next situation who is going to pay for
it how are you going to stop it from
suddenly being injected into a real war
which hasn't stopped a much pc was a
useless because a lot allowed to use
force and indeed aren't in sufficient
numbers to do so and so he he thought
you had to deal with this this was a
major unscripted event in in you end
history and you had to go very easy with
it what is interesting really how it's
caught on i must say how many people
there now in the field hundred well over
anytime yes now I must stop talking so
what these matters are all these
questions that you just referred to were
essentially not resolved when the first
note peacekeeping operation proper began
in 1956 it just began it and there was
no sort of a doctrine or general precise
had worked argue because over its on the
who Freddie I mean that it hasn't worked
out which was pretty tricky because I
mean for example we didn't have time I
hate to say this because it's posting
but we got the first UN the first
peacekeeping force into the operational
area in 10 days I'm told by it takes six
months but it's quite I don't know why
this was but anyhow over there was but
we didn't have time to brief them and
one unit labor in Gaza and the day was
ending and wet seein began the evening
prayer from there were real weddings
birthdays at the top of the riches and
one of the units thought this was a guy
calling for civil disobedience and
violence so they fired a number of
warning shots at the unfortunate priests
and is only after quite a bit of time
that somebody subject know very well
what an accident I you used to be able
to see the weather warning shots were I
totally you still can this is the kind
of thing because tip is difficult when
you put people
cultures in the same rather combustible
place without without having time to
brief them and of course it was a it was
there was a great deal I mean running
that first sounds like a great success
now but first of all you would have the
New York Times saying that hammer short
had given in to NASA because NASA had
sent a lieutenant governor of Gaza was
in fact legally Egyptian territory and
then the Arabs would say this is
colonization by force and you have huge
demonstration is saying United Nations
remember Abu QIR now why would we
remember dabble care oops I think
there's a battle with the fringe
whatever might well I mean I mean I'm
just saying that it wasn't exactly a
sort of bunch of roses the whole thing
it was very very difficult it was
managed with great skill by how
shortened bunch it was Anthony 24 hour a
day work to keep the thing on track and
that's why a response to does his
suggestion which is I think almost the
last thing he did before he died it was
extremely low key because we didn't
think that and I think that was right
you can't just you can't replicate a
success in a series of absolutely
unforeseen circumstances without getting
into a terrible muddle tell me how Brian
the first major setback in peacekeeping
was Congo was it not know the first I
would have been yes but nowhere made
this exponent force it was the corner
well now I'm amazed at the Congo I don't
know if any of you were studying the
Congo either it's hidden we want to
compare the two for us or informal
excursion was in nineteen sixty I mean
that was another thing hampshire was had
become obsessed with the problems of by
to become independent Africa
done a tour of veteran every colony and
territory in Africa in early 1960 about
it took about five weeks and he come
away with the notion that there were
some absolutely remarkable young
Africans waiting to take over but they
had had no experience whatsoever running
a stake and that this was going to be
extremely difficult for them not least
because the colonial boundaries don't
have any real reason except lines of
longitude and latitude I mean they they
cut across tribal boundaries and
economic zones and thought in a in a
completely irrational way he had been
particularly upset where he went to the
Congo because he discovered that there
were absolutely there were no officers
though Congolese officers in the in the
I'm innocent I'll congolaise the corlee
the army which was very large there were
17 university graduates in the whole
country or in some rather fancy part of
humane arts and not much used to you in
trying to govern a country and that none
of them had had any real experience at
all I mean this went for the police the
army this what was the civil service the
banked everything and he put Ralph
bunches presently trusted both out there
to wait for the independence as just see
if we couldn't avoid a frightful mess up
on the very first day well that didn't
when that the independence didn't go too
well partly because the king of the
belgians made a terrific speech saying
how wonderful the Belton rule had been
which didn't really sit very well with
the audience and and patrice lumumba who
was the untried prime minister really
suddenly showed what he was capable of
he made a blistering speech in reply to
the king of the belgians which is
something but the colonies had never
managed to do before and it was a it was
an absolute it really was an amazing
turning point the that led to a real
movement to really the bedroom thought
they were everything was going to be the
same after and depend
have been before in fact they they wrote
on the blackboards in the rooms of the
of the economy's national army they
wrote before independence equals after
independence meaning ok chaps will have
a survey and that's it will everything
be exactly the same and the currently
suddenly finding they had a very very
fiery leader decided it was not going to
be the same so you've got a clash
brought the army mutant aid the Belgian
officers mostly left and they on the
belt and civil service began to leave in
droves so you by the time we got there
two weeks later it was like that Mary
Celeste I mean you're there were the
police headquarters was empty the post
offices were all empty the telephones
weren't manned there was nobody in the
control tower at the airport there were
no doctors in the hospitals there were
quite a lot of enthusiastic Congolese
nurses attempting to learn on the job
harder to appendectomies and things like
that before led to consider avoid a
panic and it was a it was a it was a
complete meltdown it was really strange
but I won't get on to that for the time
being but now it everybody says aww what
a terrific time that was low that was
the series we would sort of read a
complete failure of it at the time and
everyone saying oh they should never got
in there it's a terrible mess and we've
got a lot of people killed and so on I
think it would have actually funnily
enough I think it could have been there
was just a chance for the Congolese that
they might have got a working government
they had cereal a doula with a very good
Prime Minister serious good prison they
had had an enormous kind of assistance
operation mostly civilian un who had
been told that on no account were they
to take over the jobs they were to train
Condoleezza on the job and leave as soon
as they could do it it was not a bad
affair but it broke up of course on
east-west lines which
read it really impossible I mean in one
afternoon the Prime Minister SAT the
prison and the president's act the Prime
Minister and then the Russian was
declared for the Prime Minister and the
Americans declared for the prison this
doesn't lead to a happy country at all
and it was a complete mess and we were
left for three years you couldn't get
any decisions at all out of the Security
Council because whatever was put up with
vetoed by thumb buddy and yet if you
didn't do anything everybody was furious
said what the hell you think they're all
doing in the corner so how much all took
the courageous the line that if since
nobody else could make it in decisions
he would and every decision or every
failure to take a decision produced a
sort of a nightmare roy from somewhere
this was a then of course on top of all
that they managed a matter of the
Lumumba v prime minister personally
having spent a little number of hours
with him he was extremely difficult I
think that he was the conga conga only
hope curiously enough because he was the
one politician in this huge country i
mean it's and it's much bigger than
Western Europe he was the one politician
who believe that we must now have a
unified Congo I think there were eight
eighty two fairly large tribal kind of
agglomerations that made up the Congo
and it wasn't really governor balazs a
unified state but a little number
thought it ought to be and if he could
have just been tamed so that he didn't
change his mind every three minutes and
didn't make all these terrible threats
which always evaporated I mean I we're
constantly being told that we were going
to be run out with blood and the sword I
hadn't heard this news since I've of a
child and I said I was quite impressed
by this didn't sound good but then he'd
always stopped I mean he and then by the
end of the conversation
back to a Fame well you know you're the
only friends I've got and so on but he
was he really had an idea about that
country and if he does only somehow
managed to mature we wouldn't be looking
at the absolutely appalling situation
there is there now a lot of it is
attributable to watch a lot of it the
karate was wrong said beware went wrong
because we had three secessionist states
which weakened the central government
and then on top of that they put in a
kleptomaniac as the president which I'm
sorry to say was the CIA's idea though
they know tonight but I mean when we
tried to point out that my boo true
though nice or sensibly a nice and
amiable chap in fact if anything wasn't
actually a Oh Barney took it and there's
not necessarily what you wanted a
country which is overflowing with
extremely valuable mineral but did I
think I think very often they out of
irritation and also lack of sleep
because with Obama had his best ideas
about 3am and we was on the blower right
away and if well after my seven nights
of this really felt that sometimes could
go on but I think that he you need to
have a serious idea about a country's
future after a great disaster and i
think he was one of the very few had one
and more's the pity that somehow it
couldn't have been used because it
should have been we could go on the
entire evening and more on on the Congo
but i do want to get you to talk a bit
about the crisis in 67 unit the or
withdrawal a unit which the United
Nations is frequently criticized as four
years of doing it right at the behest of
NASA well you know this was one of those
there's great situations where sometimes
I wonder if if you can really run the
United Nations as an integral
mental position at all because everybody
behaved extremely badly what happened
what had happened was after ten for
almost ten years of the UNF 1 the
original peacekeeping force which as I
said before was a success between Israel
and Eve everybody had got used to the
idea that you live absolutely worked
beautifully and the Arabs had got
furious with NASA and everybody the king
of Jordan on the President of Syria and
everybody else were saying there's that
goddamn NASA he thinks he's the head
Arab and there he's hiding behind the
blue helmets this won't do and so on and
NASA I apparently was not was quite
affected by this and he decided he just
got a whole lot of whole armory of i
think i was a russian or czech weapons i
think it was Russian he was very proud
of these things though nobody was quite
sure out of Wixon and so he made he sent
this completely sort of unintelligible
message which apparently should have
been something different to the
commander of unif saying the asking him
to remove the UNF troops from the
borders and from sharm el sheikh jarrah
shake which is like Las Vegas in that
time was completely uninhabited except
for two or three hots and it had 30
Swedes counting the ships that went
through the Straits of Tiran theater
here's one as my memory for names has
gone to know mine there's a quite narrow
strait which goes around goes through a
shipping goes up to a laugh the could
Israeli port and they didn't do anything
they had a they had a day a thing that
was supposed to convert sea water into
fresh water but he'd actually didn't
work very well so they were sick as dogs
most of the time but he really didn't
have the whole point was they were there
and NASA had certainly understood that
and he ordered them out surrounded them
we then had 1200 troops on a 300-mile
frontier border lightly armed not
allowed to use their weapons except in
the last resort in self-defense and
incidentally if they got into a fight
their governments would certainly have
withdrawn them instantly so this but
people knew Europe that a very excitable
foreign minister what the hell's he
called of england george brown private i
had was said was tired and emotional
which was the private i phrase but brun
child and emotional George Brian for
example was jumping up and down he
seemed to think that you nephron was
like NATO he never and it wasn't tried
to explain it that we all tried to
experience hopeless he couldn't get he
said you people are fading away before
the Egyptian dictator he said well in
the first place whether its permission
of the Egyptian dictator saina has been
an Egyptian for something like four or
five thousand years I mean it's not
exactly a new arrangement and in the UN
we respect national sovereignty and and
the whole the arrangement that not at
the baths are made with our commercial
in 1956 was it was that unif would stay
until his job was done and it would
leave if requested by the Egyptian
government after that what his job was
done to being done in about six months
oh no no they said you're just turning
tail flying and Abba Eban never wanted
to lose an opportunity to with it for a
neat phrase said it was like like like a
someone who took down the umbrella of
the moment it started to rain and then
there was a lot of this stuff and and
the New York Times editorial saying that
we found out the courage of a wet nude
remember that was very helpful it was
absolutely impossible to get any of
these people to understand the nature of
human presence and the fact that the
depth of the Israelis had refused to
have UNF in Israel as a matter of
sovereign right nobody had argued with
it now Egypt which had had them there
for 10 years wasn't because I'm that
Sauron right nonsense it was it was it
was natural and so everybody behaving in
a sort of in a kind of late colonial way
was extraordinary Canadians I couldn't
believe it the Canadians sent a rather
small battleship to the eastern
Mediterranean in case of trouble but it
would imagine what that did within in
Cairo the NASA immediately ordered the
Canadian troops in you left to leave
immediately because he wouldn't or he
wouldn't be responsible for their safety
and they would take night literally
overnight since they were doing all the
logistics and all the air stuff it was
rather unfortunate but there it was it
was I must say I've never been quite so
irritated both my government's and the
present that I mean it was simply
everybody was rattling off this this
they'd never bothered to look and see
what this arrangement world we had a
plan when I say we I mean bunch and I
and I suppose the secretary-general that
it would take is a very long time to
remove you left and the words were 3ds
very hard if they should be moving in a
dignified dependable and sound way and
this because you fairly remote in that
day this would have taken three or four
months of course we would completely
it's no good because the the Israelis
who I think you have to
advise they saw an opportunity of a
lifetime they saw a perfectly good
reason to go into theni I and take it
and also to take Sharm el-sheikh which
was which had a coastal by an Egyptian
coastal battery just behind it which
could shell the shipping into he left
and sure enough everybody does it arrive
the only person who have tried to change
NASA's mind with it was a fan to went to
Cairo nobody I don't think any senior
American person or senior brit or anyone
actually had tried they didn't want to
get into it because NASA was notoriously
difficult to deal with NASA had made
this great Proclamation and was also
trying to show the Arabs he was with
them and so that was why he did the
invasion and once he done she couldn't
possibly go back I think this supposedly
set that peacekeeping quite a long way
but then of course it didn't because the
next crisis we had everybody wanted to
peacekeeping force so that it really I
mean it was obviously that actually had
a major effect i was particularly sort
of enraged by the way that who fountain
bunch had been treated they both their
health both began to decline both the
health of both men began to decline
after that then they put a very good
public faith on it and laborious lee and
patiently tried to explain what the
reality of the thing was but there it is
it was a I don't think it really set
back the idea very much I think what has
sent back the idea actually a
peacekeeping is that the d over the
years the conflicts tended to be inside
the borders of one country with a lot of
jokers masquerading as I don't know what
are they called warlords and things like
that we don't have any kind of we had no
rules about how to deal with them I mean
the Congo was the first of these nobody
had the slightest idea how complicated
that was going to
particularly women became a Cold War
battle proxy battle field which is what
it became but the UN personnel talked to
the warlords of course what on the UN
personnel on the ground I started to the
toe spoke to the Warlord's is necessary
absolutely we talk to anybody I never
that's another thing I've never been
able to understand even I mean it's like
poor Dulles and the prisoners in China
did you really suppose that you could
possibly be seen talking to these chaps
when they were we had a possibility of a
world war on and I don't know I mean
it's very odd and it's also happened of
course it happened on a number of other
occasions with the Chinese with Viet
Cong with the Palestinians of her a very
long time I think that I wish I the the
tricky British has exactly the opposite
you were they were an imperial power
they they would talk to anybody and in
fact if they find they couldn't defeat
them they would turn whole thing into a
social event and bring jeweled gifts
from Queen Victoria and I guess I can
have tea and he went surprisingly well I
I don't think it would work now but
David at at least they weren't their
minds weren't close to to to talking to
all these fellows hi I've never been
able to understand the other approach
reverse it doesn't make any sense
because the number isn't it out that the
United States is easily the most
powerful country in the world and was
even more powerful than so that you're
not going to actually get everyone to
think you're some kind of sissy bye by
refusing to talk to the enemy it's a
good I don't know Brian one of the areas
where things have evolved is the area of
sovereignty Kofi Annan has it went on
record
saying that sovereignty in any case
isn't quite what it used to be except in
the UN exception if the temple of
volunteers absolutely for you is it
still add a temple oh yeah I mean it's
our date and everything but so the UN to
it is it well i think you know i don't
want to love I think you ought to be
talking about Alvaro instead of me but
still another one but it does seem I
mean every was always talking about
reforming the UN they've never stopped
talking about it actually since about
the third year of its existence their
idea auraria sort of tinkering with the
Secretariat mostly well every now and
then you've got a slight change will
change the numbers of members of the
Security Council something like that but
they have never tackled two or three
absolutely major problems and the reason
i think is because government still take
thee well as a kind of useful last
resort place where you actually get a
lot of things done sometimes get quite a
lot of a doubt of it and it's it's a
very good place to go to the fair up the
creek without a paddle even if you're a
great power I mean it's a nice place
you've done instead of going to war you
can come and bore the council of
everybody in the Security Council that's
fine I'm all for that but if you really
want to have an organization which has
some kind of i don't mean exactly
positive i mean positive active party
that is to say that it tries with is all
of support you want from the
government's to to get in front of
problems and really try to solve them or
try to get like we're trying to do with
climate change try desperately to keep
abreast of a problem even which is
second death then it has to be quite
different and one of the first things
that has to be done is we have to have a
public discussion about the state of the
world what we're up against and why
we're still long in the UN their
practice nowhere else on the westphalian
the Treaty of Westphalia from when is it
16 create
which also defined data sovereignty and
according to a lot of people is the
source of all the legal trouble and now
you have got to try to and I don't think
is any good constantly pushing that
under the rug I mean I used to write a
lot of the secretary journals speeches
and I always slipped in a paragraph
about this and it always got taken out
because somebody would always discover
it was in there so they know if you're
very embarrassing embarrassing my foot I
mean this is the problem and it's the
reason incidentally why you can't do
anything as far as I can see even
remotely effective about climate change
it's extremely difficult to tackle a lot
of humanitarian problems because of this
I mean you get excluded from Thailand
during a disaster you want or anything
about Zimbabwe your left just making
rhetorical remarks about four and there
are lots of other smaller less obvious
cases and the reason is that the notion
of of national sovereignty I think it's
my stronger certainly there was in 1945
I mean just tell john bolton about the
battle sovereignty I his moustache
catches fire it's really it is it is an
absolutely non discussable subject I am
now way since it's the main the
dispersment main reason why the UN
doesn't work very well and very often
can't do things it ought to be able to
do you know I think it has to be
discussed and as long as it's not
discussed we're going to have the usual
problem i'm going to have Copenhagen and
Darfur and a host of other subjects
we're here you have an international
community supposedly with very good
intentions and you can't do a thing I
think to go along with that and I dare
say this is our water but not mine you
have got to stop people playing games
with important parts of the of the
Security Council IV of the of the United
Nations and the first of those
is the selection of the
secretary-general I mean if you look at
what I'm sure Columbia I looked it up
Harvard spend something like nine
million dollars in a search thing for
its next prison and I just everybody
else does too you know they really try
to get the best possible person for the
job man or woman it is absolutely
nothing like that in the UN I mean the
most historic things happened they don't
interview the candidates they don't ask
them questions some of they don't don't
even know them by sight I vividly
remember the election of the first
secretary general actually because there
was a very nice man called edge
stettinius who was the head of us steel
who became for reasons unknown to me the
Secretary of State and he was a man
really exceptionally white teeth and
white hair and a terrific public
relations grin I mean and when they were
voting in the assembly on the first
secretary general he I was that all of
us till about eight different jobs in
those days and I one of my Jobs was the
speaker's list in the in the assembly
and he got a little table would
laborious they try to keep it straight
and he mr. tinius came out and said
could you could you point mr. Lai out to
me I said what he said yeah true feel I
you know the sky I think he's going to
be a secretary don't oh I said mr. Lee
yes absolutely he was that very fat Ida
in a bright blue suit over there oh well
thank you very much and he patted all up
to the up to the speaker's desk and made
a terrific sort of in comeon of the name
no to all we figure for about five
minutes late I have been rather naive
about everything up till I suddenly
thought oh my god you know this is the
way it's going to go and it still goes
on like that they play around they don't
have any serious effort to find there
must be all over the world in almost
every country
their money someone coming along
perfectly between the age of say forty
and sixty and even the younger than that
will be nice but I don't think the
diplomats will put up with it but who
could actually is a leader is the
charismatic person who is also highly
intelligent and who could really do a
job they don't look for it at all what
they're worried about is whether the
Chinese will veto it well that's not a
terrific qualification ready for company
today and I really I spent quite several
years of my retirement with the late
Erskine Childers trying to persuade
people that this really wasn't quite
good enough I'm you don't find Goldman
Sachs just paying up anybody at all
because there was somebody at the top of
it likes them i mean that's hopeless but
why do why do we do it in the UN this is
a very responsible job and when things
are really bad it's a very important job
alvarez and wealth of the last section
july work brother Perez de Cuellar was
an extremely quiet man and he was I must
say one of the very few people I've ever
met in public life who really i don't
think had any ego did he he said he'd
simply hated the idea of biggest liberty
and took really fairly active sort of
measures to avoid it i think i think we
should look bad on me back on him he was
a very good secretary-general he was
there at a very crucial time they turn
over from the cold war or something else
there were a lot of big crises at that
time including wars like the iran-iraq
war one of the worst Wars of the century
and he really he was quiet he was
respected he was his authority with
respect him and that's one way of doing
it I think that they should have for
example on a conference like Copenhagen
there should have been the
secretary-general or his deputy going
after the preparations that conscious
and talking to everybody for months
before it happened to try to avoid the
kind of
well really pathetic I mean this is an
exactly you know what suit you're going
to wear tomorrow this is the future if
you took a problem that you can really
possibly say is not not important I
think there should have been a much
greater intellectual effort to try to
get something which would more or less
moved in the right direction and I think
they could have done it but they didn't
and that's why I think that the you
can't reform the Secretariat you don't
have a very good secretary-general
either because if the secretary-general
isn't looking out all sorts of weird
people creep in just when nobody's
looking and and that don't help either I
think it's no question that the
secretary it's got much too big but then
all bureaucracies do they naturally grow
you know if they're the only things have
to be done by this this person and I
have some I mean to have a completely
political sort of round game about it is
not good enough having said that I can
do absolutely nobody seems to give a
damn so the Ryan there was certainly one
of the fifth secretary-general mr. Pitt
is the choir with whom you and I both
worked and we referred to earlier said
in a speech at Oxford in 1986 you were
involved in preparation of that speech
together with with me and others and one
of the things that he said was that no
one should ever be a candidate for this
position meaning that's right the
secretary generalship that was clearly
along the lines that you were talking
about so as everyone knows the Security
Council these days at least in the last
10-15 years simply awaits candidatures
to be put forward this was a you know
this is a very important point because
it originally there were nobody campaign
for it in fact i'ma short they made the
decision on him on April the first and
somebody rang him up over the AP
correspondent Frank carpenter from the
when was a terrific guy forgetting he
had some special private line to one of
the fundamentals country always new
secret decisions in advance and he rang
him up and said it about ten o'clock in
the evening in Stockholm and said how
you feel about being the new Secretary
General and a mercial said tomorrow's
april fools day and you're you're an
hour too early he had never heard of it
I mean it's absolutely true he had no he
had never heard of it there was a what
was the name of that Finn who was very
active and tried to become Secretary
General I've forgotten his name I'm an
accident it was a brilliant started what
jakab snack is called yakap yakap ssin
he was a splendid chap but he started
this business of campaigning and I think
it was a very very very he targeted
Maxie I'm he was campaigning for a whole
year it was the first person who went
all around the world and talked people
and possibly drop off little bits of
whatever it was i'm in ithaca sams I
mean we mustn't say so of course but but
he was certainly wasn't that he was
harassed though no absolutely no reason
I become absolutely standard people
campaign and it's a and what if what
that does is to close off any
possibility that that you're going to
find somebody outside the rather sweaty
world of diplomacy I mean you idea that
you could get someone from the private
sector or academia who will be wonderful
it's completely done in by this because
what you have is a lot of people putting
themselves forward and the Security
Council which is not a very imaginative
body politically to put it mildly loves
that thing can sort of list of them
neither no no the Americans will never
stand for this Chinese that's what they
spend that time doing they don't say are
we getting someone who can take this
organization from its rather humdrum
current situation and turn it into a
really number one organization on a
relatively small number of problems
obviously peace and security is one
and then the real real global problems
that actually are going to Monday
determine whether our
great-grandchildren have a decent
shortage it or not I think I mean I
don't think it's this is not rhetoric it
seems to be pretty clear I mean whether
it's a nuclear disaster or whether its
climate change and vast the specials of
this displacement of people and huge
conflicts as a result or whatever it is
I mean jibun just wonders which conflict
will finally prove to people that the
Westphalian system is out of date in
published I will of course it'll be too
late because the disaster will have
happened I mean we took world war one
and two to get as far as we've got now
and they were pretty disastrous both of
them so what will it take to get us over
the hump on so-called global problems
because it is true that if you have a
central leader who is elected by
everybody over the approval of everybody
and is has maintained their respect when
you get to some very difficult and messy
situation you they really can have an
enormous effect i think that Xavier was
very good in this way but quite I mean
somebody once said he could we could
fall out of a boat without being a
splash but that's possible unkind I mean
his method was was extreme confidence
and quiet activity and that probably is
what most governments prefer because
they think otherwise they're being
bossed around but you know you could
look for that perhaps one of you would
like to run I don't know in 20 30 years
I mean there are but the world is full
of exceptionally able men and women and
no question of it we somehow don't
manage to look for them in the UN and I
think this is the tragedy now that
person whoever secretary-general at
least bit as acquire felt rather
strongly feels still feels rather
strongly on the subject who that mr.
Perez de Cuellar
I'm editor feel I very strongly on the
subject well he general being
independent under as article 100 it's
that states should respect that well you
know if you I was just reading a book by
the heritage foundation on all this kind
of thing and they really I mean it is
extraordinary because it's in the which
is in the Charter about independence
it's led there's an article which also
asks the members please not to try to
violate the independence of the
Secretary General and the Secretariat
because they are loyal they are working
for the organization as a whole not for
one set of interest but this seems to
have been forgotten I mean they're the
bulk of the criticisms from the heritage
foundation is that the secretary it
simply simply does not not London to the
United States and therefore it's illegal
well that is these the other way around
and I do think that this is something
that's managed to somehow get lost I'm
not saying the Secretariat is perfect it
is not and it needs a great deal of work
article 100 paragraph 2 of the Charter
is not free though not frequently
invoked enough virtually never I mean
it's absolutely clear the question about
it but let me ask you about article 99
article 99 is important it seems to me
not simply because it allows the
secretary-general to bring matters to
the attention of the Security Council
most of which are on security council's
agenda in one way or another in any way
but rather because it presupposes that
the secretary-general has the capacity
to make another judgment about the
gravity of the situation the need to do
something about it has is it not a sort
of other clamor of situation that the
secretary-general really does not have
the ability to make that kind of
judgment on an educated and independent
basis well I mean you're absolutely
right this is the if you look in the
Charter v
virtually the only basis for independent
political or mediating action is article
99 material under which he has the right
to bring to the attention of the
Security Council situation which in his
opinion as a threat to peace and there's
a pretty narrow bridge if we come to
think of it but you can actually
extrapolate from that that of course if
he wasn't actually following things he
wouldn't be able to make a proper
decision it was not used I think I'm
right in saying until nineteen sixty
article 19 Island commercial used it to
call the security council by the prices
in the Congo but i think the trouble
with it is that you have to be you have
to do a lot of preparation you've got to
be perfectly clear that that that you
got support for your action before you
go into the console and call them in and
say you've got to do something about X
it's no good if one or other of the
permanent members or indeed a majority
of the council gets up and says
absolutely not that's pure nonsense stop
it that's hopeless and and I think that
there was no question in 1960 in the
Congo everybody was for different
reasons extremely worried by the break
total breakdown in by far the richest so
i think that the second largest country
in africa I mean it really was a and in
that included the Soviet Union because
they did not want to get into a into a
confrontation with the United States
over Africa they were very anxious not
to do it of course that mean that they
didn't have a 600 man embassy or waiting
to go in Leopoldville after independence
but any other when they were nervous and
in fact they were they were very helpful
they flew in a lot of the original UN
troops which I don't I don't I have who
else has used it i'm sure people have
but i can't think what they are he was a
number of times i less than but i got
less than a handful
x yeah really I can't remember I'd as I
recall perhaps someone in the audience
could go could refresh us but I don't
believe that it's been more than more
than five times altogether no I think
it's really but as I say it's no good
this is not a rhetorical device it's no
good coming in with a request under that
article and finding that you're going to
be shot down by all the government's
concerned you can't do it but friendship
you said that one shouldn't rule out the
possibility or you you even encourage
the possibility of having some major
corporate leader as a possible
secretary-general it was a corporate
leader the first thing you do is look at
the mission statement and look at
article 99 he says okay well what are
the means of which i disposed I mean UN
doesn't have embassies and don't have
any intelligence services or or an army
how am I supposed to make that judgment
well I don't think I think this I think
this will be this would not be a good I
i think that the deputy or to be the CEO
there is a deputy secretary and i must
say you've never know it but there is
one and and then the focus poor folk
have suggested this in this six-volume
report on oil for food we should attend
either there's the source for 30
musicals and asia novels and that book
it's well worth reading i think i'm the
only person who's ready certainly no no
one in the secretary-general thought is
it rated i can toting that but it but
he's he said you know it's ridiculous to
suppose that you can suddenly amount a
64 million dollar program overnight and
not have somebody who is actually in
charge of it that you have a secretary
general quite a lot time anyway you have
a pebbly nice deputy in those days who
actually was busy doing something else
and that's a lot of money i mean it
seems to me
why the UN sometimes it's amazingly
primitive and this is one of the reasons
i don't know why they could but then of
course if you call it a chief executive
officer you will have a huge problem in
the General Assembly particularly with
the the long one used to call the
non-aligned countries I don't want the
corner developing countries they don't
like the idea of the secretary-general
getting more authority on this kind of
thing they think it's a bad idea so you
know you're finish if you don't have a
job I always thought I must say to
digress slightly it always seemed to me
that the oil-for-food scandal was one of
the biggest boondoggles in the media and
not mention the united states congress
of anything if you look carefully the
corruption in terms of money with 145
thousand dollars and eighty six cents
which was supposedly the sum given to
the guy was running it now been on
Savannah what's that penicillin was a
cypriot by some oil company which is the
standard thing who do apparently and
they are afraid I mean people get paid
for services rendered this guy had had
signed in a small oil company on to the
list of people who were dealing direct
with the Iraqi government that's not
really a terrific piece of graph I may
may be very inefficient but after all it
wasn't the Secretary General who
arranged that the people providing the
goods and services to the tune of
whatever it was 64 billion would deal
direct with the Iraqi government we did
one that wasn't the idea of the
secretary-general it was the Global
Security Council on wishes we all know
the United States and the British and
every of the veto so that there one day
where they could you couldn't have
stopped it he only trouble with that was
of course that the Iraqi government
would not have gone along at all without
you so I think it was I think that this
huge Papa see the what was the
who disputed some in the Savings and
Loan scandal in 1986 it was fifty five
hundred and something billion you know
under here to read the New York Times
saying this is the biggest financial
scandal ever well I mean I may be but
tell that to the poor akis who were
being supported under heavy sanctions
all this time by this program was what
allowed them to have a semblance of our
life and our actually I should should
Eun have turned down that no no I think
I think that they should have insisted
that there that if I mean I think there
were a lot of people in the Iraqi
government their last chance to be on
the take so it if it was vice good for
them and of course if you were doing
good business oil companies aren't
necessarily supposed to be boy scouts
are they I don't know I mean I think
when you mix these cultures up and then
you have a secretary general in that
case Kofi Annan who Washington is
furious with for other reasons then
you've got a problem I think I think
this was there were about three
newspapers in the whole country who
actually tried to describe what actually
happened and it was not good but it
wasn't it was not the greatest scandal
in history or anything like that no not
by a long chalk and it did actually work
up to a point fairly well considering
what a different and incidentally a lot
of the eye under stand it I mr. i
retired twenty six years ago so as I
have no idea what I'm talking about but
I've been told that you there was a
whole sort of sector of Iraqis who were
the distributors and the people on the
ground and on the Holy did extremely
well and they're the people now who are
really helping in the sort of
reconstruction and so on you think
that's true
I don't see who else he and I do I don't
see why that wouldn't be true I uh but
that that sort of brings at least me to
the subject of sanctions of that kind
otherwise known as crippling sanctions
would you think about the notion of
sanctions living back well your mass
actions were were considered quite
seriously to be the alternative to war
all through the 20s the only trouble was
that nobody ever imposed them and flood
i know i don't think they put sanctions
on muscle anyway and very invaded
Abyssinia for example or Ethiopia's at
night there every do-gooder insight but
I was a boy was it was yelling that they
should do it and I think they should
have done it why not who's invaded
another country sanction so they never
really very much been tried is it true
that they refined sanctions a great deal
so that neither a target on our got
aware that it doesn't actually cause
terrible suffering to the population at
large and actually targets ministers who
want to go to Las Vegas or something
like that or indeed have a lot of money
stashed away in Switzerland I think so
but that work there seems to be a
turning point a turning point when
Madeleine Albright I believe she was
already Secretary of State at that time
who said that sanctions are actually a
blunt instrument and that therefore they
can have sometimes consequences are not
the desired ones and that the the whole
notion of punishing a the people in the
expectation that they will rise up
against a
the mutaters somehow slightly flawed and
then they moved to targeting them I
think that the day is a key moment there
was after a mission to Angola during
which they realized that the way to do
it was to somehow put a corner on the
diamond market and if you just do that
that that could have some sort of and
effect but the original notion in the
Charter whether where they're not
referred to as sanctions the as I
understand it the spirit of the relevant
articles in the Charter is that the
purpose of such measures is to modify
behavior rather than to punish as seems
to be frequently the case well you could
say I suppose that sanctions on south
africa did have i don't i have no idea
what this drawer took a long time but
they took a long time but i think it did
very much affect the business community
and so they became very anti apartheid
like them have been very difficult to do
anything I is that true or not i I've
always thought it wasn't I think so I
don't know who thinks that should
everybody take part in this because I
before if you are willing than I mean
nothing more if you are willing but
today there's actually someone standing
in the margin with a with a my with a
live microphone how is some how would
people say that if they get through
security council the latest volume was
the series of stringent sanctions would
affect Iran it seems to me this is a
very tricky situation to get into I mean
but I don't know people have somebody
here must have studied at ion or perhaps
they have other concerns what would
anyone like to ask a question oh yes yes
you are very very governors oh wait wait
there's a there's a microphone headed
for his another direction just now
they'll come back to you yes I'm sir
Brian
I wanted to ask what your feelings are
about the Security Council these days
and whether you are in favor of
expanding it or change you in any way
from what it is now hi Steve overlord
well I don't think you can it seems to
me we have a built in an insoluble
obstacle to expanding the Security
Council namely that none of them their
main regions can agree which is top
nation and therefore should be a
permanent members and that the main
problem oh I mean you have three in
Africa least two and Latin America I
don't know what nature sell it if it I
mean it's almost I wonder really I mean
it does seem to me was it is another
sort of virtually antique a part of the
antique character of the UL that you
have a the main body of the UN is
actually represents rather imperfectly
the power balance in the world in 1945
and here we are in 2010 that doesn't
really make a lot of sense and I don't
know what you think they'll ever sold it
I don't think so I mean everybody gets
very annoyed when anybody else puts up a
plan but that's not really the same
thing as progress is it I don't know
what meanwhile other thing goes on but i
think it is it's an Achilles heel to the
organization there well i'm sorry mr.
Damania irrumation very correctly
evening after reading that
I don't like to be much authority to the
Secretary General you have been very
close to the first second
secretary-general and you must be
knowing very much closely about his
character and about his techniques what
was the most important factor which
instigated deck never sold to carry most
of the government with him and with his
program and they had so much confidence
in his initiatives well that's a how
much time have you got I mean I'm a
terrific ball that subject I warned you
but nonetheless i will try to keep it
short how much it was a very unusual
person he had virtually no small talk I
mean it be it wasn't really a sort of
blast to spending a lot of time at
Hampshire because he was so serious and
furthermore he was reserving his energy
for more important things I once I was
very peaceful myself I was one of the
people who ran the first international
conference on the peaceful uses of
atomic energy was an enormous conclave
of scientists in 1955 and it was the
first occasion when both the United
States and the Soviet Union and a lot of
other countries Declassified enormous
quantities of nuclear information so I
was extremely important and i wrote a
kind of a short current of this
conference and hammer sure it was Hamish
Bowles priority for that particular year
he loved it because he liked
intellectuals and after all most of the
physicists were intellectuals and so
they had a grand old time was fine and
he was and he was very pleased with it
and I sent him this note which I taken a
great deal of trouble over about 25
pages trying to describe it and I got it
back instantly with the following
inscription I still have it thanks but
no time well this was actually he was
absolutely concentrated on the task and
he was a bachelor and having a domestic
problems
I know and he he was that he was an
intellectual in action which is a very
nice combination I think he was also a
very I mean he made a huge impression on
people and I've never been able to
account for that I mean you could go to
Rio de niro or New Delhi or Tokyo the
taxi driver would know who I'm sure was
and would have a curiously accurate but
simplified idea what he was trying to do
now that is that is something for
somebody who was a very bad speaker who
had no sport or ostensibly very little
charisma how did he do this I mean what
are the Swedes though that we don't know
that's what I've always wanted I mean it
was extraordinary and on top of that he
was a practical intellectual I mean his
capacity for thinking up alternatives
which would actually be even better than
what they were discussing already and
seeing round corners to wear something
would either move forward or get stuck
he was incredibly good at this he could
I think he could do something which I
certainly can't do it I don't how many
of you can which is to sit by himself
and think about a very complicated
problem let's say the American airman in
China or something like that and after
about an hour come out with an
absolutely coherent plan with
alternatives for talks in China country
never been to and didn't know I mean
that's sort of where he was very unusual
but why this got through to large
numbers of people i do not know i mean
if that is very strange and as i say was
his trouble was that that he was a bit
too good for the permanent members of
the Security Council one of the reasons
why they seem to be extremely anxious to
avoid having an intellectual again in
that job is it he is hammer sure because
he started off telling the United States
they should
over the government in Guatemala in 1954
or I think that was a very good piece of
advice and Ivan nonetheless it didn't go
down well and then the United States
greatly to his credit and that was Henry
Cabot Lodge I think realized after the
Chinese American prisoners that you
couldn't expect hammarskjld always to
agree with the United States but
actually he was infinitely valuable
nonetheless because if you were really
in a jam he could be of great help I
mean every day and people did respect
him for that even Khrushchev who got
into this really manic state and started
banging shoes links even he went a
mercial died said Hamill was a very
great man i have to admit it and that
was the reason why he was mad with him
the early person who never became
accustomed I'm sure it was Charles the
goal who thought he was some kind of a
bj a fellow getting him to try to get
into this sacred group of great power
heads of state and that was a not a
relationship made in heaven mammoth a in
fact very general did is that will best
to to sabotage I'm already am sure
whenever he could but i think that i
think it was the mixture of intellect an
enormous he was I supposed very
religious in a very weird kind of
mystical way and he read books on
mysticism as if they were novels I mean
he was everything I think this was a
huge part of it I think that he just was
a very unusual character and I don't
suppose we'll find any more like that
again but that's not the only way to do
it i mean the whole point about that job
is we have to get somebody really good
who will decide how to do it best in
their own way I mean it's like I've you
decided that he was not going to be a
known by every taxi driver in the world
and so on and never chance to anyhow it
was this style I think you can you know
once you get the
the intellectual and the the sort of
moral ethical quality after that you
just gotta look for somebody who has the
stamina to do it and it's hard to do
that unless there is some sort of
systematic search process I mean we
don't consult we the security council
doesn't consult the anybody in academia
about this they don't do they do they
don't go out and consult great corporate
organizations I mean they're a lot of
very intelligent people in the corporate
world why they make so much money
immunity they've got would have a lot of
good advice to offer we don't do it we
look about a very very limited circle a
circle and a sort of oldboy net we've
never had a woman secretary-general now
can you believe it after 65 years since
I read it's really terrible yes question
here
thank you so much for everything those
far it's been absolutely fascinating I'm
taking a course with romani ginno mostly
on peacekeeping but one of my favorite
phrases of his that he's repeated over
and over again is that the strength of
the UN is its weakness and I was hoping
you could comment on that that sounds
like one of the questions in turned on
it the strength of the UN is it lies in
its weakness so the weakness of the
greatest I quite sure there isn't
another phrase i I have a huge
admiration for somebody incidentally I
mean he's a wonderful fellow so if he
says it and any ideas I think there's a
miss something missing at least my my
understanding of what he means by that
is that there's no there's no sort of
underlying agenda or that there's more
of a perception of neutrality maybe that
anyone can use to its advantage I
believe that's what he means by that as
well I think this thing about neutrality
actually is attended to get rather
confused I think objectivity is a better
word because after all there are some
situations in which both civilians and
the military do have to take decisions
and actually do something which I have a
lot of other people don't like it was a
bit of luck that we proved to be right
in the end but but you know I think I'm
not sure about your trial tea i think
it's a it's a it's a state which which
applies to particular states who have
neutrality of their constitution that
it's very well but i don't think i don't
think the UN is that i think it shall be
impartial to impartial and objective
that's and intelligence incidentally
which is not always quite the case you
know those are the three things it had
and neutrality well I mean neutrality
for what it's I think you should not I
think one of the great things but that's
very difficult now to with dealing with
internal situations in very vers la via
or any number of places the awareness in
Maui is is you have to try to not become
the the advocate of one party you could
not do that particularly in states that
trying to be democratic but I still I'm
puzzled I think I still have to call
about math game especially if you keeps
coming back there's question here on
first row mr. Brian if I can bring you
back to the palestinian-israeli conflict
I said what to the palestinian-israeli
conflict I think it's it's it's an issue
that the UN has invested huge amounts of
efforts both in in a way in creating the
conflict with the partition plan of 1947
and also positively for example with the
contribution that uemura as an example
has made to the two Palestinian
nationalist movement in creating an
educated class what do you think has
been the impact of the conflict
particularly the genesis in its in its
beginnings in the UN and the obsession
and ultimately the failure well I'm not
sure you could speak of either
successful failure that cultic diamond
seems to me that you have to take in
very small stages otherwise but that of
course is a rest Bashar not Soviet and
whether it's not soluble of all I'm not
so sure well Alvarez a great deal more
about this than I do I always thought
that well partitioned in the first place
is a terrible idea it seems to me I mean
how many partitions do we have that we
know a disaster that's India and
Pakistan which was the Indian
subcontinent which created a huge
casualty list
really not a very satisfactory situation
for either of them are too low island
not very good cyprus you know i think
that i don't know why they the Partition
Plan have been around since before
watching before world war two and Bunsen
burner dot put it into the final
recommendation because they simply
couldn't think of any other way that you
could even attempt to stop what was
beginning to be an almost permanent said
war in their summer of nineteen forty
eight after israel became a stage and it
have been very very violent before that
and i think they just felt that you had
to do this i don't know whether that was
an irresponsible thing but it was about
the only thing that you could get both
side well not that you could get the
Arab states to agree on it one of the
great problems at the beginning was the
Palestinians were not represented as
Palestinians they were represented by a
group of Arab states headed by Egypt and
this certainly didn't help the
Palestinians at all and it made them
have made their position I think very
weak at a time I'm i think was just a
necessity I mean if you have whatever it
was four hundred and fifty thousand
refugees in the first goal and even more
after nineteen fifty sixty women's it's
67 you have to have some way to look
after them and i must say that i think
the the whole thing of vocational
training and reducing from the camps a
whole class of people who really were
very very valuable in the whole area I
mean people who did a huge amount of
work for example in place like the Gulf
and thorn and were very important given
all the other suffering the Palestinians
have had to undergo this at least with
something and after allowed if the New
York Times is right over you know if it
wasn't for andhra people in Gaza would
be 50 times worse off than they are
already so I I don't I think that one
has to it's just a pity that you
to prolong the a huge what essentially
was a refugee organization at to begin
with over a period of what is it 60
years now 60 so that the other thing was
they you know something really the
solutions used to me to have very little
to do with reasonable common-sense if
there ever is one it takes a lot of a
lot of heavy boosting from outside to
get any agreement on this at all quanah
yarin who is the Swedish UN
representative after after 1967 for
three or four years I think God as near
as possible to producing some not
perhaps a final solution but at least a
very large step towards it with the
whole concept of land repeat what lantra
peace yes man for peace but y Arlington
I mean he didn't have any clout he has
no military cloud he had no economic
slow he had no financial clout he was
just one jolly old Swede and a very good
one too he was terrific but there was
simply no way I mean I imagine George
there now of course of things infinitely
worse than it was then but I imagine
George Mitchell if he ever gets anywhere
near to a successful some kind of
successful solution does have a lot a
lot of useful power and cloud to push
things along and and I think I certainly
true of this I think that at the moment
that the really terrible problem is is
that the Palestinians themselves about
uniting you have a complete sort of a
scizzum between Hamas Hezbollah and
Abbas the father and and this really
puts everybody but seven an impossible
position to look at it's very easy for
the Israelis and say that they can't
deal with the movement which is divided
in two at least
well I think this occurred yeah i mean i
don't think the security constant our
alvaro you should talk about this
because your money by far more recently
engaged with this and i am come on no no
I mean clearly there there is a problem
i can't imagine that it is not
understood by the powers that be that
the only way to have a viable agreement
between israel and the palestinians is
if the Palestinians are reunified and
speaking more or less as one but at the
same time that is not acceptable to too
many because one of the two Palestinian
wings or sighs Hamas doesn't meet
certain conditions which on their face
they they can't possibly meet I mean for
Hamas the idea of recognition of Israel
whilst under occupation by Israel is
simply a non-starter its form of
legitimization of the occupation so if
some way can't be found around that it's
not possible to produce a viable
agreement by viable meaning and
agreement that the Palestinians broadly
will accept and live with Aunt operate
because the other thing is there is a
very considerable question I supposing
there was agreement whether these state
of affairs in the West Bank is
susceptible to becoming a Palestinian
state and I mean never this is all very
much changed as everyone seems to assume
that the outcome of a solution that the
parameters are well known and accepted
by everybody and they talk about somehow
combining
the Clinton parameters of early two
thousand and the Geneva Geneva
initiative 2002 but of course they do
not provide for a viable Palestinian
state they do not establish connectivity
between that Gaza and the West Bank they
do not give the Palestinians control
over their airspace or their subsoil I
mean their number of the attributes of
sovereignty which can remind room there
I I'm not sure whether the solution is
there but on the other hand even for
that it doesn't seem possible with the
eggs within the existing Israeli
political system to produce a solution
that the Israelis can accept now you
have an in order any Israeli leader is
faced with a dilemma of well can I reach
an agreement with the Palestinians or in
order to reach an agreement with the
Palestinians that will work i would have
to give up my coalition I one of the
first people the first person i
interviewed here was slow mo benami who
who spoke about how when they were came
to Camp David and afterward to Thabo I
believe it it was for these negotiations
by the time they got to Camp David they
had lost one of their coalition partners
and by the time they got back to Israel
it was just Barack and he Barack and
slow mo I believes more or less those
are the words his words you use can't
put and get it through the you know
there are members of the Israeli
coalition who have
you know as their main agenda to that
there should not be any negotiation
regarding Jerusalem for instance but I'm
going on and on and this is this is
about getting your views Brian and I am
frankly sir Brian when listening to your
account of a cold war history and the
role of the UN in it you might get the
impression that the UN was actually very
much at the center working with the key
countries at the time really being a
mediator being a respected organization
when you read the press nowadays you
might get a slightly different
impression there are lots of articles
and discussions about the
marginalization of the UN regional
organizations are taking over the g20 is
getting more and more important so my
question is and of course and also the
emergence of China we're getting a much
more you know difficult word there's not
one one one country that resets the
international agenda anymore and can
dominate so my question is where do you
see the UN heading now is the UN
becoming irrelevant or where do you see
the UN in there in the coming decades we
are the opportunities for for for action
thank you yeah well I think you know
people always look back and see the past
rather Rosie spectacles I mean it seemed
to me we were overcome by tremendous
class of abuse firstly all the time
whatever we did but now everybody says
it was all so wonderful everything I
think there are two things which will
which in the first place the UN does a
huge amount of stuff which nobody's ever
heard of which I think would be
seriously missed if it didn't happen and
it's not very exciting I mean statistics
okay very important there are likely the
whole thing of the development in the
calendar law it's very important it
isn't it
it's not a it doesn't keep you awake at
night but but there it is so that's one
thing as to its I mean it's whole
central object has kept changing we were
originally put up to stop world war two
from happening again as I mentioned at
the beginning with aggression economic
disasters and getting rid of of the of
the Imperial world then we that was
quite a success I mean decolonization I
think was it well that I'm see
historical development of extraordinary
importance which is what's given us
where we have now which is you know many
ways much more difficult to run but it's
the right thing to have done and that's
it then I'm never quite sure about
globalization because I don't really
understand about it but but he does seem
to me that if globalization has happened
it hasn't been much of a success except
for a very small number of people it
really has not been very helpful to the
developing world it's produced a lot of
problems which would have been there
before there are now at least four or
five areas which could be nearly
terminal for organized life on this
planet now everybody's always talked
about that but it's never been quite
like this there's never been anything
quite like pandemics which are produced
by a huge amounts of air travel and
thought only way you get a something
there starts in a village in Mexico can
turn out to be a disaster in China I
mean this is new nobody has ever had the
array of weapons of mass destruction
which now exists in the world not just
nuclear either there are now quite a lot
of movements to to say that all
government is wrong and corrupt and
international
governance is even worse I mean there's
I don't think the sort of international
tea party parties yet but that I accept
less would call al Qaeda one I mean
sussing me their objective is to do in
is due in governmental order around the
world and re-establish the Caliphate
well that's fine but the only trouble is
what's going to happen to do to all of
us it's not going to be and we know that
there they have a very brutal though she
loved doing it it'll be 50,000 times
worst if any of those get even the
simplest of weapons of mass destruction
I'm thinking or chemical or biological
weapons let alone serious nuclear bombs
there's climate change well if I mean it
does seem to me that this sudden
eruption of people saying that it
doesn't really it's not really happening
is painful and absurd they see this
really is an ostrich act of unbelievable
Salinas and soon royal I mean you know
the Maldive islands I believe I'm right
saying or buying territory on the main
lab already because they just simply not
going to be there not to mention the
poor old polar bears and everything this
is not this is going to affect almost
everybody if we've been told by very
reputable besides it's not necessarily
the whole you air and group is it but
you know Hansel are only people who
rushes watch will spend their lives
studying there that you know we were
almost reaching a point wishing a point
of no return but every time anybody gets
up steam about something we get some
huge distraction I think that the
function of the UN should be to maintain
a level discussion of matters which are
extremely important which governments
very can't handle and governments are
going to have to somehow be persuaded
that that complete national sovereignty
line but it really is pretty irrelevant
when you have world destruction in
who have world I'm in a nuclear exchange
of any great with greatness would be
unbelievably destructive I can imagine
that the biological weapons might be
much but worth the long run anyhow we we
have the capacity due to our huge
technological revolution have all these
things go wrong but to make that stick
you have to have very impressive people
running it you have to have people who
governments will take absolutely
seriously and you have to have people
who are capable of communicating so that
the public is able to make decisions at
the moment as far as I can make out I
don't know whether it's true that
virtually the whole public blog gets its
news from cable television but if so god
help us all but you know you've got to
somehow get the public interested in
their own survival and I think that that
again is something that the UN is failed
has recently failed to do you've got to
try to get back to a notion of
international politics and international
affairs which is intimately connected
with the public and I don't I mean it is
very noticeable East I've always find it
very noticeable if you go to the
schedule a tour the Nordic countries all
of which of over the years spent a great
number of young people the peacekeeping
operations almost anyone who talked to
has a far better idea of what the UN is
about then somebody in the United people
in most people in the united states
united states have not had large numbers
of young people at an impressionable age
involved let's say in Cyprus all the
Congo or some other gossip late you know
this is very important education you've
got to somehow or other get into the
heads of people that it isn't all the
sort of media game this and and you've
got to get into the heads of governments
that some of the things that if you're
going to pay large sums of well not very
large sums of money but fairly large
sums of money for the UN year in year
you might as well get your money's worth
in which case you need to stop it
properly you really have to I mean I'm
astonished at the I many old ebay will
say whatever this is really political
matter don't worry a little head about
bodily organization that's going to be
the good old Chinese in the United
States and and Russians everybody
hackneyed I midnight and just asking
each other who they won't veto I mean
that's what it amounts to is there's no
sense but I don't know if this is this
is not a view that it's very easy to get
across because most people I think we're
finally bored with you well you know it
is a talking shop why not but and you've
got to really try to emphasize the the
priority things that organization ought
to do I personally have always thought
for example that it ought to a much more
effective in peacekeeping which means
having a permanent establishment and a
permanent establishment is genuinely
international so that you can't pin on
any units of a UN peacekeeping force
that it is nothing but Pakistan is
always nothing but fins or something
like that that's wrong you have to but
this is up step which is now so far away
I don't think we'll ever get to it I
mean it used to be that a lot of
governments were interested in that
nobody is interested in that because P
skiing works all right it's sort of
models along all right so five million
people got killed in the eastern Congo
in the last six years but you know
that's the way it did this is terrible
and I you know that I just feel that the
government assessment of the UN is that
there it is you know we pay for it and
everyone that's incredibly useful and
puzzle all the time isn't and therefore
you have it kind of kind of gradually
falling to bits i did i said i bought
what puzzles me is which of the
potential cosmic catastrophes is going
to persuade governments and people
around the world that the treaty of
westphalia is not
I mean that we the principles of
national sovereign states is over and
it's over in virtually all fields except
diplomacy line so there we are as we
have another question right if you can
thank you I wanted to ask you about your
view on un reform as sort of never
ending story in the UN and particular
reform of the UN Secretariat what do you
see as the the key priorities in order
to reform the UN Secretariat as an
institution to meet global challenges so
today you know any answer our gift for
that is going to be extremely
self-serving because I'm going to say
something I'll say it but what I I in
the first place we need to get back into
the Secretariat the kind of the kind of
spirit and general feeling of enthusiasm
that we have all over us a very good
case in point is a surviving person like
this but quite a lot of people with the
Secretariat I think just giving coupons
ready and it's easy to say that it's
incredibly difficult to change it you
are going to get huge opposition
especially from developing countries if
you start really cutting down on the
Secretariat and yet a bureaucracy gets
into this state after bidders we're
going to 65 years so there's a big
political problem right there certainly
having a very tough at very good
secretary-general and a really good
tough deputy would help because you've
got to the only bus was actually done
this as far as I know is how marshaled
who who actually spent 18 months doing
everything when he was first arrived
doing absolutely nothing except
wandering around the world looking at
the UN in various places isn't deciding
what was necessary and what wasn't and
then you figured out a plan that you
didn't need to fire anybody very much
would just move people around a lot some
people good retire anyway and somehow
you weren't going to call
individual suffering and the secretary
but you get a much more workable
Starfighter physically I think he did do
that I think you've got to stop
government smedley in it which they do
all the time I with candidates I had a
well I was there I had a very useful way
of avoiding that which was to keep my
office improbably small and if any by
any chance died or got shot as I mean
you concealed Legion you but until you
filled that position dimitrios otherwise
you have from all over the world drunks
people who are hopeless cousins of prime
ministers I mean there's a huge pool of
these people and I'm not joking it's
perfectly true with it and and you have
to have a tough of operation which
doesn't mind telling governments know
otherwise and how much I could do that I
think that I don't know about sure about
have you been such a nice chap I'm not
sure a bitch but you know you cannot run
that kind of thing well if you were a
very is a question you don't get the
best people and cuz there's no room
people want any good and that's what we
and we have awful we have geographical
representation so it comes second in the
charge of the companies have a little
more and then I think a lot of the
activities of the UN a very
old-fashioned I don't know you ever
attended a meeting of the Committees of
the General Assembly but you know they
never use one word where 2,000 will do
when they go on for months this is not a
way of impressing the public it just
isn't I think that maybe one has to
think about the whole setup of world
diplomacy I mean some of my best friends
at the brats but I but you know that
they sometimes make you want to kill
them they take in really critical
situations you know you just wish that a
trap door open late
I mean I started life as a soldier so I
need to sever an unreasonable view of
getting going and getting things done
but but you know I think this was for
this was for the 19th century when it
took six months to go from Madrid to
London and you know you had people there
who were really going to be there for
ages and really became part of the
country they were diplomats and we're
very useful because they could give
general representation they really
couldn't deal with emergencies now the
capacity to deal with emergencies is
it's very it's very ill served in the UN
I mean it does it is makes no sense to
take six months to deploy a peacekeeping
force in Sierra Leone or somewhere where
people are dying by the thousands every
week that's nonsense and and but you
know you can't get a discussion on that
loud so there we are but perhaps one
last question with you because we're
very witching hour one well every time
I'd like her friend when for last three
and a half years as a journalist and
it's been very interesting because I'm
seeing various things it seems to me the
serious problem that I see is that the
Security Council could have done the
weapons of mass destruction in Iraq and
there were no weapons of mass
destruction all those resolutions led to
the u.s. being able to get the
resolution to invade and then the UN
became the supported being the u.s.
being the occupier and so that's I think
the legitimacy of the UN is to have this
kind of activity going on and it just
seems then there's no lessons from that
instead the same thing appears to be
happening with Iran there's a dispute is
enrichment for peaceful purposes allowed
or is is it going to lead to the ability
to build a bomb in a country like Iran
and this is this is a dispute over the
NPT and yet it's it's become the
Security Council
then doing the same thing and the press
doing the same thing you're threatening
military action and invasion so is there
some way you see in your long experience
of of the UN of legitimizing the UN
again having a way to to not let the
Security Council get out of hand the way
it did with Iraq and well I think I'm
actually doing me I'm the last person in
the world to blow the trumpet for the
Security Council but as I recollect it
there's a kind of Vegas Security Council
absolutely dug its heels in and said it
could not possibly support a the
invasion of Iraq and in fact George W
Bush then said that of course the UM
would be what is it open or obsolete
what he had a wonderful word and I'm
everybody was kids actually I thought
they were right about that I mean they
were you and it took quite a lot of
moral courage don't buy the British
would be with it yeah yeah but I get
your point I mean I do think it is true
that they I had thought when I first
joined the UN which was just there 19
late nineteen forty-five that as members
of the Security Council government
representatives would behave with the
interests of the whole international
world in mind well dream on I mean no
way and that's the problem that's what
your toys I don't do it everyone's
something sometimes people try to do it
but it's very and I think this is one of
the things that you need to have in a
public discussion or where we have got
politically I mean are we still a world
of sovereign independent untouchable
states or are we are we going to become
something different because eventually
we're going to have forgotten something
different anyway and already in most
walks of life we become different so I
mean I think this is the big think it's
really the problem you're talking about
what you have going on in the Security
Council's it sounds like 19 5 in your
it's you know it's a lot of people
talking past each other and making
compromises on it doesn't it's not very
impressive it's better than nothing but
but I mean I think and I think the other
thing is we desperately need sort of
useful and fairly revolutionary
suggestions from the outside world
especially academia I mean it doesn't
mean the other why we have a talk about
sanctions which I know nothing about but
you know there'd be a prime university i
think it is has a whole program on there
to actually turned out to be quite
useful to the Security Council they or
where they were projecting some ideas
about how you would have more targeted
sanctions less destructive more
effective and so on and I think there
must be hundreds of subjects like that
which a little fresh air and fresh
thinking would be wonderful and I very
much hope that you will produce that and
run to secretary general Brian thank you
for bringing fresh air
you